where are they now tfu do you remember
when fortnite felt like the single
biggest thing in the world it could turn
your run-of-the-mill twitch streamer
into a worldwide household name and
chief amongst those who fortnight
crowned was tfu 28
from dominating the early days of
fortnite friday tournaments to becoming
one of the first members of faze clan's
fortnight roster tifu exploded with this
game he and closey went on to win the
summer skirmish tifu competed in the
fortnite world cup in a leopard print
vest became embroiled in a year-long
legal battle to get out of his contract
with faze clan and then challenged ninja
to a fight you either get in the ring
and be a man and let's do this or like
just shut up and never talk about my
name ever again so what is he up to now
tifu has settled into being one of the
go-to places on twitch to watch top tier
battle royale gameplay he chained his
success from fortnite into a large
following in call of duty warzone and
then he was able to seamlessly
transition into the top apex legends
lobbies he also maintained his passion
for calling games dog getting
savagely stream sniped and while doing
whatever this is